pull yourself together Paulo pull
yourself together
you don't need American Idol you don't
need a lot of those things in life you
know why why Paulo because there's so
many things in life that people miss out
on so you're not gonna miss out on
things because there's so many hobbies
there's so many hobbies
maybe one of my hobbies is I can go
travel yes I'll go travel oh good don't
go to space I'll go to the moon I can't
do that why not Paulo I can't easy there
because because there's a song called
rocket madman
Bobby's saying the first season of
American Idol don't remind me okay okay
maybe maybe you could do something else
maybe you can just just give back to the
community maybe you could go to Africa
and help the black kids yeah that's what
I'll do I'll just go help Africa no I
can't do that why can't you pal why
can't you because because Taylor Hicks
saying he'll the world don't don't make
me go in Africa okay won't make you go
to Africa don't worry okay
well let's see there's got to be
something this this gotta be something I
just know it
that's it bracelets I just love my
bracelets baby
uh I just uh getting the bracelet
industry that's a really good idea isn't
it I just wear my bracelets and that's
it that's what I'll do somewhere oh by
the rainbow oh no what spot what's the
matter Paul katharine mcphee sing that
song somewhere over the rainbow
I'm just clapping because she's saying
it so beautifully katharine McPhee is
not even here you sing it girl you sing
it because I certainly can